I didn't watch the show till about 5
years ago I was hooked it's it's a show
that should go down history is one of
the great great shows of television in
history in the top 10 it was the best
thing in the it taught me how to really
act
because you know Peter Berg handpicked
everybody on purpose for the reasoning
that he wanted people to just be raw you
would walk into a room and there were
three cameras no marks
and just be like go and then sometimes
you know he'd whisper something in my
ear and then go to plem and whisper
something in his ear and we say whatever
it is and then all of a sudden we have
this whole different Dynamic going and
then we go into the lines and it just
created this really cool environment to
to work and it was really hard to
relearn how to you know walk up to a
mark